you guys are in for a real treat we do
have an opening act though yes we do in
their name
was play what is cosplay cosplay
originates from Japan its costume play
and it basically is dressing up as a
favorite character we've never done
cosplay before I get to be an Asian lady
Anime Expo invited us to perform at
their masquerade in front of thousands
of people in Las play is like Halloween
every day at Disneyland exactly
Christmas can suck my dick Thanksgiving
can get because Halloween is the best so
cosplay is gonna be amazing we don't
know what characters we're being we've
never watched anime we've never cosplays
we have no idea what our sketch is gonna
be this is a nightmare if anyone's
interested they should at least try it
well we're the try guys and we're gonna
try it the try guys try cosplay episode
1 the try guys watch anime we should go
to Anime Expo as anime characters yeah I
would suggest it just because you might
get more people appreciating it I don't
know much about anime I know that they
have huge beads of sweat and they fall
down anytime something happens one thing
I know about anime is that everyone
looks like Eugene that's racist not
because he's Asian but because of his
fantastic hair yarmulke me
hey we're here with Funimation we're
gonna talk to some voice actors here our
works kind of in vindicated because it
was like all animes an ish things we
both got into this like in the late 90s
when there wasn't much anime if any at
on television anime fans did not get
enough credit for the general mainstream
which they are starting to now so since
the other try guys are really unfamiliar
with anime I picked some scenes from
series that are really iconic because we
need to figure out which characters were
gonna go out Wow steaming out of his
mouth
I see his butt going that ass that's a
med butt mmm is she paralyzed by fear
that's a boy what are all these short
naked people yeah like what they're
naked is very arousing what oh my god
and blood come on
Japan this animation is gorgeous it is
it's beautiful just better than most
movies well we're talking about cosplay
were talking about badass weapons these
guys got going spat as weapons
it's like Game of Thrones put animated
animes like hey here's your favorite
character sorry
I mean Keith kind of got that Titan look
though yeah I really do look like some
of those Titans they know that alchemy
is a real right for this world out face
real you cannot make gold out of just
any old thing that is the opening
sequence of this anime why are they
always blowing up mom's anime just
people losing their legs and moms dying
why are their costumes all Revolutionary
War period I've noticed in a lot of
enemy shows they're inspired by like
different time periods
there's the bald man with the cute baby
hair he's a bad guy you know villains
are always trying to stab people in the
dick and then they just get away so
they're dicks don't get stabbed
I thought watching cartoons was gonna be
fun but it's just making you really
saying it's crazy how anime can jump
from something so serious and and
traumatic to something fun and goofy and
light yeah I guess we're having a good
I totally get why you would want to
emulate these people because they're
very strong they're like heroic it would
be fun they rule it would be fun to
pretend you are this person fight
choreography and this show is great
though every movement has a specific
sound in anime which is really fun oh is
there a word for that sound react react
react react yeah they'll call us up and
say you have a 125 lines and 800 reacts
would you mind giving us a really good
react to each ah that's every time I
make toast and a toast comes before I'm
ready for it I try to do the fight
reacts in real-time so like that merrily
in Japan when people turn their head
they make a sound like this you'll
probably learn about the character as
you make them I recommend picking a
character you like because the cosplay
creation process kind of cars they know
how to start a show these credits are
off the hug yeah it's like anime
openings are like music videos wait this
is still the credit sequence yeah his
hair is terrific what's the secret maybe
it's mabeline maybe it's in your like my
book like - you're great now widen a
doubt what I think Japan does is really
cool is that they're able to tell
dramatic adult stories through animation
it's weird to have a main character who
I don't like I would much rather watch L
story than light story and he's always
sitting like this I feel like I'm ready
to poop I was gonna say poop yeah yeah
this was cool but I don't see anything
for cosplay here I say next evolutionary
girl I'm a revolutionary girl what is
soutane I mean that just reminds me of a
UTI but that's her name med how old is
this character can we lust after this
character no they're all pretty much
between 13 days why are they showing so
many legs god those men have gorgeous
locks this is like our one chance to
have hair as good as Eugene we get fancy
hair you're stuck with your stupid
perfect hair yeah why is there fly down
to metaphor for how upside down life is
is a
she's just getting the sword that
resides within the princess wow that was
very section my high school was nothing
like that my high school was nothing
like this right I was in Van how many
American cartoons can you name that have
a girl that has a sort of kind of
romantic way ship with another girl and
is basically dressing in boys clothes
Dora the Explorer like with their anime
Japan is all about empowering people
that our media does not empower at all
and they were doing a way before and in
children's cartoons there we still don't
do this I've always said impress
interviews I'm so honored to be a part
of something that brings so many people
together you look at the crowd here you
got every age every ethnicity both sexes
all sexualities all political
affiliations religious affiliations and
everyone comes together and we live in a
society that tries to point out our
differences and draw us apart and we are
lucky enough to be part of something
that draws people together yeah this
show got talking cat I am totally oh my
goodness she finally let me and that we
can respect I don't have to real sorry
though her name is Usagi Usagi oh
there's literally a dream I've had that
a talking cat come into my bedroom and
tells me I'm a pretty princess oh my god
equation I've seen it before I know this
oh she's naked no she's she's 14 she's
no she was naked now she's just came on
she's got brake lights in her hair I
think half of Sailor Moon is actually
about them getting good grades if you
don't have Asian parents you just have
to know that if you get bad grades she's
white these girls are what they are
defecation okay they look white they
look new Asian they're obviously in
Japan that's a whole conversation in
anime politics we can talk about later
but they are blonde white girl I know
Caucasian when I see one
Bubba powers the best power yeah no it's
not it's completely useless well she's
also harnessing the power of soap oh she
cares she kind of looks Japanese yeah
she look Japanese fire is way better
than bubbles No
I don't know about that sometimes I get
hurt and all I can get was oh so the
penises had that cute big-ass bow kind
of like naked big old butt all right
Mercury's got that Google glass she goes
into the rocks in the second yeah yeah
she's like they're like hard rocker they
were legit killing people there's so
much action and like adventuring the
animation is so engaging even if it's
geared towards girls I watch this as a
little boy oh yeah I love this show
I like this one the best because it's
digestible yeah about friendship also
they murder people how our friendship oh
I'm just gonna cramp your knee hugging
each other the best thing about cosplay
is there's just no rules so whatever you
guys want is available to you we want to
do rule 63 right we want something that
W crowd these are at the masquerade
opposite and that we can do comedy and
inhabit the characters accurate I think
Sailor Moon might be the way to go so
now that we think we have a good idea
the hard part starts yes on the next
episode of the try guys try cosplay will
Zack ever recover from an exhilarating
battle with hot glue will Keith assume
his true form as a Titan can Eugene be
more Asian right now racist wait
also Ned's but stay tuned to find out
what happens when the try guys make
Sailor Moon costumes
oh my god hahaha that scares me every
time